we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p here's a voicemail that
came in let's take a listen to it David
my name is Kelly I am calling from
Indiana it's my first time calling but
I've been listening to you for a while
okay I've recently heard that you went
on a trip to Indiana and I just want to
let you know not everybody from Indiana
is like that there are I would say a few
progressives that aren't trumpet in
Indiana so yeah just wanted to clarify
Indiana's Matt and all that state thank
you
right no I knew that I did meet one
person who wasn't the trumpet during my
trip in Indiana out of about fifty or
sixty but I know that Indianapolis
actually is comparatively speaking
relative to the rest of the state
there's a lot of lefty stuff going on in
Indiana yes hashtag not all indianians
not all isn't it Indiana's I like that
better indianians and I like how she
says there there are a few reasonable
people yeah out of you know like the
millions that live in Indiana overall no
I believe it I believe it there are
absolutely reasonable people in the
great state of Indiana Mike Pence not
one of those people great bonus show for
you today
david pakman.com slash membership to get
access patreon.com slash david pakman
show will also get you access